we begin tonight with our todd chrisley
exclusive
the outspoken and larger-than-life star
of chrisley knows best
is rocked by legal trouble and so much
more and only our rachel smith sat down
with him
in nashville rachel you had a lot of
ground to cover so many scandals kevin
tax evasion blackmail and the whole
family
came ready to talk we haven't sat down
with anyone
you're the first interview that we've
given since all of this we placed
no parameters on this interview we said
ask us whatever you want to ask us
there have been a tremendous amount of
headlines about the two of you
your children todd and julie chrisley
facing charges
for financial crimes this is a serious
indictment
you think that you would be facing all
of these
legal issues family issues if it weren't
for the reality show
and becoming famous well i don't think
so because then nobody would care who we
are
the state charges have been dismissed
but where do you now stand with the
federal charges um we're still working
through that process
the chrisleys who deny any wrongdoing
still face a 12-count
federal indictment including tax fraud
claims
and there's that other scandal their
estranged daughter lindsay
claims that her own father tried to
blackmail her with a sex tape
he told me that chase had incriminating
evidence against me
nude photos and had obtained this tape
for five thousand dollars there was
never any extortion that was all used
for headlines
that was used to gain social media
following where do you go from here
you're currently estranged she's our
daughter
and i will tell you that the anger was
there for a long time
revenge and anger belongs to the devil
so i walked with the devil i was dancing
with the devil there for a minute
you know this is a job but at the end of
the day
all the to go away and this is our
family i want to know more about lindsay
she recently announced that she is
getting a divorce have you
heard from lindsay i received a text
message from lindsay about two weeks ago
and i turned that over to our attorneys
why um
because we don't feel that it's safe to
communicate
today lindsay's rep tells e.t quote she
has tried to discuss these matters
privately she ultimately decided to
leave the show when it was no longer a
healthy environment
of course todd and julie's marriage has
also been the focus
of tabloid fodder your mother was
sounding like
well i keep arguing more and more maybe
they're divorcing is our marriage
perfect
no it's not but i do think we have this
mutual respect and we've both agreed
that we're not throwing in the towel no
matter how tough things get
they support each other my mom's got his
back and he's definitely got hers
they've set a perfect example of
what we want and what is a healthy
relationship
chase and savannah kick off season three
of growing up chrisley
thursday night on usa network right
after chrisley knows best
i want to lighten the mood a little bit
so first episode of the new season
todd your love of botox
is next level
what is your frequency what is your
botox
budget i go for botox once every four to
five months
and i will say there are times to where
i've looked at him and i'm like hey dude
you're starting to look old you need to
snatch that back now is there any kind
of procedure that you regret
getting well i really haven't had
anything other than my botox okay and in
your good jeans and i had my
i had my upper and lower eyelids done
okay um
and that's i mean that's it so i mean
i'm good
i mean i feel like that when the time
comes i'll go and do whatever i want to
do
i asked todd where he sees himself after
reality tv
and kev he told me going into some form
of politics